elle se pose c'est la question du
réchauffement climatique et le la cause
principale qui a été analysés par les
scientifiques du réchauffement
climatique c'est l'augmentation des
émissions enfin l'augmentation des gaz à
effet de serre près
un réchauffement entre est mécanisme de
réchauffement et la question principale
c'est comment baisser
l'émission de gaz à effet de serre et
pour ça il ya deux réponses mais ces
deux réponses méritent qu'on les écoute
en prenant en compte ce qu'elles veulent
dire première réponse il faut baisser la
consommation autant qu'on peut pourquoi
on isole les logements c'est pourquoi on
fait on fait attention à la consommation
des voitures que l'on cherche des
consommations plus faibles deuxièmement
on substitue au carburant et aux sources
d'énergies fossiles qui viennent du
pétrole du charbon du charbon enfin se
rassurer et du gaz ont leurs substituts
l'électricité d'où vient l'électricité
d'électricité pourquoi l'électricité
parce que l'électricité elle n'émet pas
de gaz à effet de serre quand on
l'utilisé à l'endroit où on utilise et
surtout on peut la produire sans
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
comment produire l'électricité dont
qu'il ya là encore de réponse très
simple la première c'est on va trouver
des énergies renouvelables de l'éolien
du photovoltaïque et naturellement il ya
des gens qui disent on peut qu'on pourra
tout faire comme ça et puis il y à
l'électricité nucléaire qui est produite
alors ça les gens le savent pas parce
qu'il ya des sondages qui disent c'est
l'excès le nucléaire qui fait le plus de
gaz f et elle ne fait pas du tout du
tout dans du drame voilà ça on le sait
donc en france on a fait le choix du
nucléaire il ya quelques décennies en 58
réacteurs aujourd'hui on va enfermer 14
d'ici à 2035 donc c'est important
et la question qui est posée c'est de
savoir si on en fabrique l'autre pour
continuer en france à voir ce mix
énergétique électricité produite par des
énergies renouvelables électricité
produite par le nucléaire et à la dezir
positionnement une question de mix
énergétique accord à première vue on se
dit voilà on va on va trouver un
équilibre
mais le ce dont il faut prendre
conscience c'est que l'électricité
produite en france par des unités de
centrale nucléaire
c'est la condition même pour qu'on
puisse avoir des énergies renouvelables
d'accord parce que le photovoltaïque
c'est le soleil il n'y a pas du soleil
tout le temps dans la journée dans la
nuit en tout cas y en a pas l'éolienne
et l'éolien c'est notre jour du vin ce
sont donc des énergies intermittentes
si on n'avait pas le nucléaire on serait
obligés d'avoir des centrales thermiques
au pétrole ou au gaz et on augmenterait
nos rejets de gaz à effet de serre donc
il faut compter continuer à compter sur
le nucléaire dont j'ai fini vite existe
à mon sens et au sens des analyses que
nous avons faites avec l'équipe du
commissariat au plan
il n'existe aucune autre solution pour
le pays que d'avoir cet équilibre d'un
côté énergie renouvelable développer de
l'autre nucléaire et donc il faut
programmer la suite c'est à dire la
survie le potentiel du potentiel de
production d'électricité nucléaire en
france alors ça évidemment c'est
important françois bayrou il faut
programmer la suite
edf qui est le grand architecte comme
credo de toute cette politique demande
depuis déjà longtemps
quelques années l'autorisation de mettre
en route
6 pr2 fabriqués à nouveau des réacteurs
6 pers est pour l'instant le des
pouvoirs publics le président de la
république parce que c'est lui qui en
dernier ressort décide n'a pas répondu à
cette demande
emmanuel macron mady au plus tard en
2023 il faudra répondre à edf
alors j'ai deux questions simples est-ce
qu'il faut répondre oui d'après vous à
edf
et est-ce qu'il faut répondre oui avant
la fin du quinquennat d'après vous il
faut répondre oui à la décision de
construire ou de mettre en place de
nouvelles unités de production six pays
cités sans émissions de gaz à effet de
serre alors la question est ce que ça
doit être des repères ou autre chose
vous savez le prêt elle est ouverte
voilà cette question là est ouverte
parce que il ya à la fois les opm
flamanville en voit la difficulté arrive
en ville c'est des difficultés parce que
on a monté le seuil de sécurité
on l'a on l'apporté à un point tel qu
évidemment ça coûte extrêmement cher
puis à d'autres propositions de faire
des unités de production d'électricité
sans gaz à effet de serre nucléaire plus
petit d'accord mais là aussi la question
du gigantisme et la question faut-il des
nouveaux réacteurs notre réponse est oui
où il ne peut pas faire autrement parce
que nous courons tous droits les
réacteurs vous avez rappelé leur nombre
les réacteurs qui ont été mises en place
selon été mis sur une très courte
période
au début du septennat de françois
mitterrand c'est là qu'on les a inauguré
le plus oui il ya quelque chose de bon
et c'est une très courte période et donc
ils vont arriver tous en fin de vie en
même temps il ya ce qu'on appelle en
effet falaise en va-t-on peloton dette
et donc il fait donc programmé mettre en
place et je crois c'est ce que cette
note vise à montrer qu'il n'y a pas
d'autres solutions disponibles sauf a
recommencé à émettre des gaz à effet de
serre ce qui est absolument le contraire
de la politique que nous avons décidé et
sur laquelle nous nous sommes engagés
internationale est-ce qu'il faut que
cette décision soit prise avant la fin
du quinquennat
en tout cas elle sera au niet à la fin
du cac animé il nous restera elle sera
un des sujets de campagne il n'ya
occitana question la question et macro
radio plus tard 2023 pourquoi parce
qu'en 2023
normalement le père de flamanville sera
mise en place et à ce moment là on
redessine l'ensemble de la stratégie
industrielle
c'est une chose quand on est président
de la république de dire d'autre que moi
peut-être moins si je suis réélu
décideront ou bien puisque je suis en
situation de décider je sécurise ce
choix et je le prends avant la fin de
mon quinquennat
est ce que c'est votre souhait françois
bayrou vous voyez que on est en train en
ce moment à l'assemblée d'étudier toutes
ces questions climatiques
il n'entend pas dire on parle de
l'écologie résilience
on ne parle pas c'est clair ce matin je
serai auditionné par
il a par la commission du développement
durable de l'assemblée et on va en
parler
j'imagine puisque je pense qui vous
auront entendu mais je voulais parler
pendant la question si je peux répondre
à votre question
si je ne dis pas non
d'abord jeu j'essaie de apporter les
réponses qui sont les miennes et pas les
huîtres moi j'ai pas de réponse à une
question je pense que ces questions
doivent être prises que ses réponses
doivent être apportées ces décisions
doivent être prises dans les allées deux
ans qui viennent donc pas forcément
avant la fin donc ça va être un des
sujets de la campagne présidentielle je
n'ai aucun doute de ce point de vue là
que vous le dites si le président de la
république pense qu'une décision doit
être prise de ce point de vue là je n'ai
pas de doute qui le fera parce que je
sais que c'est un sujet qui n'intéresse
même le passionne mais si vous dites que
c'est une décision qui doit être prise
dans les deux ans qui viennent vous
admettez l'idée qu'elle ne soit pas
prise avant la fin du quinquennat
je voudrais citer pour terminer sur ce
sujet barbara pompili au mic d'enquêté
la ministre de
la transition écologique qui présente
actuellement le projet que nous
évoquions à l'assemblée nationale on
étudie la solution pour parvenir à 100 %
d'électricité nucléaire avec des
énergies renouvelables si possible dit
elle non non je pense que deux de ce
point de vue là vous savez dit la
ministre à temps de chien que le savait
mais on peut on peut avoir des
désespoirs on peut avoir des rêves vaut
mieux ne pas avoir d'illusions tout ça
c'est la même échelle dans la grille
j'ai de france c'est la même échelle et
donc le c'est normal que la ministre
pense que un jour peut-être on arrivera
à la totalité de mes les raisons
techniques que j'ai exprimés que j'ai
exposé dans cette note est qu'on peut
trouver en ligne sur le site du plan
point fr ces raisons techniques montrent
qu' à l'évidence ça n'est pas possible à
court terme pourquoi parce que quand on
produit de l'électricité il faut
transporter l'électricité il faut des
réseaux et c'est pas du tout la même
chose
l'électricité qu'on produit avec des
cellules photovoltaïques sur le toit ou
avec une éolienne
parce que c'est du courant continu ou
stock paraît alors voilà c'est un
problème alors que l'électricité qui
parcourt le les fils électriques dans
les villes et les villages cette
électricité est en courant alternatif
donc c'est très compliqué de transformer
l'une en l'autre mais on va pas entrer
dans ce débat mais des gens j'étais sur
la pédagogie des jarres et en gt on
enferme j'étais plus jeune j'étais
sur les questions de l'électrique
engagés sur les questions d'électricité
les électriciens disait l'électricité
c'est comme les fraises des bois à ça ne
se stocke ne se transporte très bien on
a fait des progrès et en stockage
l'hydrogène est une manière de stocker
l'électricité
on a fait des projets des progrès en
transport est pour l'instant en effet ça
n'est pas aussi simple que l'on veut
bien le dire parfois et donc je crois
que on a besoin des deux pour l'avenir
je crois que votre message a été compris
je suis sûr qu'elle a été entendue
partout où il doit l'être
la situation sanitaire alors laissons
gang du gouvernement sont moyens les
attestations c'était n'importe quoi
quelquefois on est un peu désolé par la
gestion de la crise sanitaire
l'êtes vous aussi françois non je pense
pas du tout ça je pense que les pouvoirs
publics le président de la république le
gouvernement ont pris une décision
essentielle mais qui n'a pas été
présentée avec me semble-t-il caractère
particulièrement juste de cette décision
apporte c'est de laisser à tous les
français retrouver le plein air on est
confiné
parce que on doit éviter au maximum les
multiplication du virus mais le plein
air a ceci de particulier toutes les
études qui viennent de sortir l'ont
montré qu'il n'y a pas de contamination
en plein air c'est le sillon d'un gars
c'est le slogan dedans avec les miennes
dehors un citoyen oui les slogans shake
shake your fait marrer fait d'accord et
donc le
vous voyez si à l'extérieur on garde les
distances de 2 m il n'y a pas de
contaminer mais là c'est l'hôpital qui
en train de craquer loyers en ile de
france
tout tout tout les hospitaliers 10 mais
on va continuer comme ça on peut pas
tenir et c'est pourquoi ils ont c'est
pourquoi les pouvoirs publics ont décidé
de ces mesures de confinement en ile de
france n'est pas assez sévère des années
hospitalier région oui c'est en première
ligne il faut que vous compreniez ce que
ce qui frappe tout ce fut maire d'une
ville on ne peut pas enfermer un pays
complètement mais c'est pas la question
mais si une question c'est qu'est
l'hôpital tient pas mais qu'est-ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous cherchez à
prouver qu' il faut pas sortir de ce
soir je cherche à prouver pas grand
chose mais si les gens qui cherchent à
prouver les gens qui sont en première
ligne dit vous cherchez vous chéri faut
pas sortir parce que jaune et bien ce
n'est pas vrai vous entendez ça
toutes les études montrent c'est
pourquoi je trouve qu'il ya beaucoup de
confusion dans ce débat et que tous
observateurs ou acteurs on doit essayer
d'y mettre de la clarté
il n'y a pas de contamination à
l'extérieur et l'ex et sortir ou en
plein air permet d'échapper à
l'impression d'enfermement qui elle
aussi est en danger pour les personnes
pour les personnes seules pour les
familles qui est pour ceux qui ont un
tout petit appartement et c'est quelque
chose qui détruit aussi les équilibres
psychologiques et psychiques et donc
cette décision de rendre le plein air
pourvu que pour le reste on air les
locaux et qu' on ne se rassemblent pas
comme on l'a fait trop souvent si on
fait ça alors on respecte les combles et
les précautions à prendre pour que la
transmission du virus se fasse moins
parlons de votre combat françois bayrou
vous souhaitez que la prochaine
assemblée nationale soient élus au
scrutin proportionnel pour qu'elles
soient davantage représentative de la
diversité des français le parlement
notamment l'assemblée nationale ne
discutera pas de ça vous souhaitez un
référendum et en avant
les élections législatives on se demande
donc vous en vous quand vous l'aurez
vous l'aurais perdu sans doute mais moi
c'est pas mon sentiment
donc moi quand je mène les combats c'est
pour les gagner pour les gagner
autrement n'a pas de sens c'est vraiment
ça n'a pas je suis là on a l'impression
que l'aï perdu oui vous vous avez là
puis longé droite à voilà moi pas et
donc on verra pourquoi parce que vous
voyez bien qu'il faut à tout prix
changer quelque chose à la manière dont
ce pays est gouverné je sais bien que
c'est pas votre avis c'est pas si c'est
important comment vous y arriverez c'est
sa gestion ce matin je n'ai jamais cru
que l'assemblée nationale comme
discuterai prendre et résoudre cette
question alors qui pour de bain le
peuple français leur ai fermé à cette
idée là de écarquillés pas les yeux
parce que vous faites semblant donc il
faut qu'il faut essayer de garder cette
idée là qui empoisonnent les débats
politiques depuis 40 ans je vous
rappelle que françois mitterrand 1985
avait fait voter et que les élections
législatives de 86 ont eu lieu sous ce
régime de la proportionnelle dallaire
c'était mon premier mandat et on a eu et
on a eu une majorité oui ya eu une page
aurait une majorité pour la droite qui a
gouverné à l'époque mais un référendum
il faut que emmanuel macron le décide
elle a que lui qui peut le décider ma
position est un peu différent oui comme
vous avez vu j'ai rassemblé des
signatures très nombreuses de courant
politique très important et qui sont
majoritaires dans le pays
les écologistes le l'extrême droite
l'extrême gauche tous les toutes les
parties du centre c'est la majorité des
courants politiques du pays ils ont tous
écrit au président de l'asa je sais mais
comment est ce qu'on arrive ça vous
savez vous mais peut-être ceux qui vous
aiment et la roma on a beau le savoir
dans le jeudi cette question qui
empoisonne le débat politique au lieu de
passer son temps à la promettre à chaque
élection ça a été le cas de tous les
présidents précédents et à ne pas
la réaliser il suffit d'en remettre la
décision aux français et donc on se
tourne vers eux on se tourne vers eux et
on dit voilà les seuils à kamanyola
tranquille peut le faire qui peut le
faire mais moi je ne propose pas que le
président de la république s'engage sur
ce sujet d'accord mais il propose qu'ils
demandent à ces formations si elles sont
un texte qui pourrait les rassembler si
elle propose quelque chose
et à ce moment là comme on le fait en
suisse les référendums suisses vous le
savez c'est pas le pouvoir qui s'y
engage ses les citoyens on demande aux
citoyens français
quelle est leur choix pour l'avenir et
ça réglera et tranchera donc vous
espérez que cette question d'anyama
quand s'engage dans un référendum qui
aurait lieu le jour des élections
régionales c'est ce que ce que je
souhaite les élections régionales veut
savoir et du logement voilà faut savoir
bah ça dépend uniquement du sanitaire et
vous accepter l'idée qu'elles sont à
portée des prescriptions que le haut
conseil chargé de la santé va faire
d'ici au 1er avril pour dire si oui ou
non ils pensent que ces élections est ce
que je sais est entre ses mains entre
ses mains et on saura très vite
est ce que je peux vous poser deux
questions simples françois bayrou pour
terminer le question très simple par oui
ou par non à l'erreur oui eh bien je
suis pas sûr que les questions par oui
ou par non sont des questions simples
est-ce que vous souhaitez canadien de
maquereaux fasse un second mandat soit
candidat à sa succession
je pense que la logique c'est celle là
mais sa décision n'est pas prise et il
faut attendre que sa décision surprise
mais vous le souhaitez je pense que
c'est un président de la république à la
hauteur de ce que nous vivons vous avez
abdique à l'idée d'être vous même à
nouveau candidat j'ai vu qu'il y avait
des déclarations sur ce sujet alors je
vais vous dire une chose
il ya un moment où il faut arrêter de
dire des bêtises et il faut se
concentrer sur l'essentiel l'essentiel
c'est ce que nous avons dit là le
sanitaire la crise économique qui vient
le social si on peut éviter et lication
peut éviter de jouer à ces jeux
perpétuelle dans lesquelles
on prend les élections comme une course
de petits chevaux
je trouve que c'est mieux donc on
n'avait pas répondu à ma question oui ou
non est ce que vous avez dit que je ne
réponds pas aux questions dans la rue ou
par non quand elles sont vicieuse donc
de ce point de vue là je vous fais
crédit pas de réponses aux questions vie
chère lady cheval c'est votre ligne
françois bayrou mecs merci d'avoir
accepté l'invitation des leucémies et
maintenant ça donne le temps avec vous
marie aline mais lier bonjour et aline
bonjour jean michel bonjour à tous après
les questions vicieuse on va vous
raconter une histoire ubuesque
en pleine crise sanitaire alors que la
france l'union européenne sont en manque
de dos et c'est une urgence